- We went through all of your
comments in the previous video
- and picked out the
weirdest combinations.
- Now we gonna eat 'em.
(whooshing and creaking)
(upbeat music)
- Have you ever dunked a chocolate
chip cookie in some nacho cheese?
- It just looks wrong.
- Ah, you went deep, girl.
- I hate it.
- Loved it.
- Honestly, it's, what's weird
is both of these foods are sort of
so middle of the line
that this tastes bland.
- It tastes like somebody dropped
a bag of salt into a cookie mix.
- Just savory, like, the cheesiness,
the salty and the sweet,
is actually kinda good,
which I'm disturbed by.
(upbeat music)
- It smells like I'm putting
steak seasoning on watermelon.
- It smells like an old attic.
- Okay, cheers.
- Cheers.
(upbeat music)
(table thudding)
(man and woman laughing)
- Nice.
- Like that.
- It's, like, everything
at your backyard barbecue.
Like, the barbecue chicken and
the watermelon all at once.
- What hellscape have you
brought us to?
- How do you
get it out of your throat?
- The salt makes you thirsty and then
the watermelon quenches your thirst.
- It tastes like I just
swallowed the ocean.
(upbeat music)
- You would do me, like,
sip it through a straw.
- [Voiceover] If you want to.
- Shut up.
- Actually, suddenly this
is way more exciting.
- Ew. I didn't get anything.
- It's funny to taste spicy
things through a sweet thing.
(upbeat music)
- What is that flavor?
- It's like a spicy soy sauce.
- What if I got fruit
roll up mashed into it?
- Together, it tastes like bile.
- Like, the spicy, tangy part
is like the touch of vomit.
(upbeat music)
- No! (laughing)
- How dare you make us eat
bananas and mayo again.
- I'm thinking about the
last time I ate this.
- So salty.
- I'm so sad right now.
(man sobbing)
It was so bad.
(upbeat music)
- Nope, nope.
- There's that little dab of mayonnaise
that makes me hate myself.
- It tastes like oatmeal.
- It's just solid mush in your mouth.
- But this, I don't know.
It's like, sweet.
It's weird.
- Another?
- There's no flavor but evil.
- I don't think it's evil.
I just think it gets a little desperate.
(upbeat music)
- This is literally,
like, a three-year-old
was able to make his lunch.
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah.
- Come over to my house every day.
- I'm into this one.
- This is super good.
- Definitely.
- It's like a smoky peanut butter.
- They're both kind of, like, dry tastes.
- Yeah.
- The bologna isn't too sweet.
- There's no weird texture.
- Peanut butter and jelly? No.
That was so 2014.
This is the year of
peanut butter and bologna.
(upbeat music)
- I would vote for that.
(man laughing)
- I did.
- Peanut butter and bologna, two K 16.
(whooshing and creaking)
- Great.
- I'm having the best day.